[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome Penn
Alexander
thank you thank you guys Wow New York
City everybody here we are city of
dreams that's how they bill it right
city where dreams come true have you
looked around does it look like people's
dreams are coming true out there oh look
a Mexican man delivering Chinese food on
a bicycle just like he always dreamed
back home a family digging through the
garbage for bottles and cans because
they're just that passionate about the
environment do what you love and the
money will come a nickel at a time
people working two and three part-time
jobs into their 30s and 40s having two
and three roommates a lot of people seem
to have that dream in New York and it is
common true living in New York is like
one extended game of how well are you
hiding your poverty and depression some
days you'll hide the poverty better
other days the depression but when you
get that balance just right oh people
say look that guy's dreams are coming
true
[Laughter]
let's get a selfie with him everybody's
hustling to New York overworked
underpaid sometimes you just get hired
for jobs you didn't even apply for I
Drive a 2007 Toyota Prius charcoal-gray
nondescript but now that uber and lyft
exists people just get into my car
routinely just recently this young woman
gets in my car announces we're going to
Brooklyn starts waving her girlfriends
over I'm like whoa whoa we're not going
to Brooklyn she's like excuse me
I'm like I'm not a cab driver she's like
what I'm like this is not a cab I'm a
person who has a car and drives himself
places he needs to go and then she was
horrified when she realized that she
like ran out traumatized into the
embrace of her friends as if I had done
something wrong it's like you broke into
my car and she was so sure of herself
that I was like maybe I do work for uber
like is this how they hire you someone
just gets in and like all right we're
we're in Brooklyn where do you I just
want to get a good review
I hit a cop car with my car I don't
recommend doing that I was driving home
with my fiance we were just a few blocks
from home we were passing by this cafe
that I go to from time to time I noticed
it peripherally that they were open
later than usual so I turned my head
like oh they're open later than usual
when I turned back the words police were
getting closer and closer I rammed into
the cop cars bumper and my fiancee to
her credit didn't say anything but I
could just feel everything she was
thinking I was like you're right you're
absolutely right about all of it
the cop car we're at a light the cop car
turns off to a side street so then I
turn to my fancy like should we just get
the hell out of here like no we can't do
that so then I turn and follow the cop
and pull up behind him now all of a
sudden say I'm pulling him over maybe I
work for the NYPD now so then we're just
sitting and waiting cop finally gets out
ambles over first thing he says is bad
idea hitting a [ __ ] cop car I was
like yeah actually it wasn't my idea
just happened then he was kind of like
pacing around like you remember when you
were a kid and your parents were almost
like searching for the punishment they
were beside themselves so I'm waiting
finally he's like [ __ ] it I don't want
to deal with this I was like that was my
solution
[Laughter]
then he goes you were never here which I
thought was almost existential like or
any of us ever really truly here then he
turns and walks back to his car as he's
about to get in he turns back and says
oh are you okay I was like yeah we're
fine are you okay he's like yeah
gets into his car drives away I turn to
my fiancee and say I don't know what
these black folks are complaining about
that could not have been a more pleasant
exchange
I felt saved by felt detective I felt
like my life matter
[Applause]
it was like we were thrust into a
commercial for white privilege if you're
not sure whether or not your life
matters I suggest that you hit a cop car
just see how the rest of the exchange
goes it'll be a little different for
everyone
results may vary some assembly required
my fiance and I took a jar of coins to
the bank I don't know if you've ever had
to do that as an adult but it's somewhat
humiliating you don't even get to talk
to a real person they have this animated
character named Penny Arcade it's like
would you like to take a guess at how
much money you have I was like first of
all this is a serious financial
transaction can I see a manager or
somebody with a tie on
but secondly yes we would like to take a
guess actually that sounds like a lot of
fun we weren't prepared for that if we
could just huddle up for a moment that's
within the rules $50
that was our guess we were way off
123 dollars and 17 cents oh we jump as
if we had won the lottery everyone in
the bank was looking over we were like
coins you can turn them into real money
get in on it diversify your portfolio
ask for penny tell her we sent you I've
never been that happy in a bank before
so my fiance and I are getting married
in October we're gonna have a
heterosexual wedding we decided
got to discuss everything these days you
can't take anything for granted I said I
I identify as the groom she's like I
feel like the bride it was a great
that's one thing down
let's talk appetizers we had a bit of a
love story we dated
ten years ago and I fell in love with
her as soon as I saw her just instantly
fell in love felt that connection but
then she broke up with me she didn't
feel it the same way she was young she
moved to Italy for school and work and I
was broken I was devastated I was
pathetic
have you ever been pathetic like really
just an embarrassment like you can see
in your friends face they don't even
want to be around you it's like oh he's
gonna tell us the story again it was
very raw
you know you feel alive but for all the
wrong reasons
started making bad decisions started
visiting her mom basically started
dating her mom
I just needed to be close to someone who
was close to her but then finally I got
my [ __ ] together
moved on broke up with her mom her life
was good again I felt whole I felt good
years went by dated other people then a
couple years ago I got a text message
out of the blue how are you and you know
how you recognized the old area code
Saigon 908 look who's back right on time
how are you
that was like today or the last eight
years the answer to both is fine send
because you gotta be a man about it
right can't give it up too soon gotta
play it close to the vest but inside I
was like dear diary you'll never guess
who's back I'll give you three little
hints 908 give up diary it's her
[Music]
I was excited it's very excited we went
out for coffee then we went out to
dinner and then she moved in beside we
could take it slow this time and it's
funny because you know how you have
different friends who react differently
you know you have the friends who are
like unconditionally supportive hopeless
romantics my friend Danny was like Teddy
if there's any love in this world run
towards it as fast as you can I was like
thanks Danny I'm gonna do that and I
said but don't you still live with your
wife even though you got divorced five
years ago it's like we're talking about
you right now this isn't about me that's
fair that's fair game then you have
other friends who were more like
protective of you right they hold a
grudge for you right my friends like
don't let her back don't let her break
your heart again I was like I don't even
know if I have a heart I'm 48 years old
I just want to feel again who cares
break my heart so what did feel good to
reconnect with the one who I always
thought was the one but she's different
you know she's an artist I'm a comedian
so we've committed to a life of struggle
[Laughter]
but she just fascinates me I like the
way she sees the world she's different
she was raised by lesbians I don't mean
she was abducted and taken into the wild
she was raised her mother was with a
woman and they raised her and her
siblings and every now and then it just
hits me just little moments I can't even
explain and I'm just like ah that's
right
raised by lesbians they don't care for
men I am a heterosexual man I've always
been attracted to females but there are
certain guys who make me nervous you
know what I mean like every now and then
I'm just like oh hello I never know when
is gonna happen like there's this guy
that works in the bagel shop in our
neighborhood I can't even make direct
like he is the most mysterious blue eyes
I can't even look him directly in the
face like as the line moves up it's like
I hope I get him but I also don't hope I
get him like my heart is beating faster
my mouth is dry finally I get up to the
front I'm just like cream cheese you
decide
I don't know what it is I'm not sexually
attracted to him but I just want him to
like me that's really so we've
reconnected again it was beautiful there
was an age difference and there still is
that's how math works but it feels like
less now because time has gone by we're
both older like if I took her to my high
school prom I would have been pushing
her in a stroller like no no trust me
guys I have a good feeling this is gonna
work out okay now it helps her sleep
[Applause]
oh she is in her very early thirties and
I am in my late 40s they say a woman's
sexual prime is her 30 so she is in her
sexual prime and I am NOT I'm past my
prime like do you remember when Shaq
played for the Celtics that's me
he didn't look like himself anymore he
had a hard time getting up and down the
court some nights he was really an
embarrassment and I bet there were
nights where Shaq's teammates got very
angry at Shaq and said like Shaq do you
even want to play with us you have any
passion for the game anymore do you care
and I'm sure Shaq was like no guys it's
not bad at all I love you it's just that
I'm a little older now it takes me a
little longer to warm up maybe if you
could just [ __ ] be a little patient
Jack probably said to them
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and I just think it was very unfair of
Shaq's teammates to treat him like that
he was a legend he had done a lot in the
game he deserved better and if you look
back Jack had some really good games for
the Celtics not every game not every
game but on some nights he looked like
the Shaq of old and I just wish his
teammates could have appreciated that
instead of harping on the night that he
had difficulty performing I feel for
Shaq is what I'm trying to say the older
you get and the longer you've been with
somebody the sex isn't as important as
sexual threats here I mean you just
gotta throw it out there like ah
someone's gonna get it tonight nobody's
gonna get it you're just gonna watch
Netflix and go to bed but it's just nice
as a gesture to put it out there in the
air
it's a nice thing to do oh you better
watch it you're gonna get punished like
what go to bed like what's the
punishment we know what's gonna happen I
proposed on it on a Wednesday on a
random Wednesday just because I felt
like anyone can do it on a weekend when
it's supposed to be fun you know but I
felt like Wednesday would really set her
up for what our home marriage is gonna
feel like it's gonna be a real Wednesday
energy to the whole thing and as soon as
she knows that the better so it was very
it was just you know it was an exciting
time being back together after all those
years at times it felt a bit like a
corporate merger where certain
departments are no longer needed
and they were mostly the departments I
was in charge of my job is to see to it
that all devices remain charged I take
it very seriously I'm always on the
prowl I'm like honey give me that you're
at 11% thank God I was here crisis
averted
that's what it means to be a man in 2017
just like I think we have an outlet over
here for me
keep the family safe
[Applause]
seventy percent above that's my rule
cuz she'll let it get down to like the
single digits I'm like we're not animals
I have out what's all over this place
how do you live like that
she handles all food-related decisions
she just took that over unilaterally
that's her department I never know
what's next I just have to stay on my
toes I'm discovering that women all have
this side thing as a nutritionist it's
not licensed not certified but they're
always talking to each other looking up
articles reading the latest stuff it's
like this Underground Railroad of
nutrition that men aren't privy to and
it's always changing coconut oil was a
big part of our lives for a while I
don't know if you're familiar with the
wonders of coconut oil but if not
prepare to be wowed there was nothing
you couldn't do with coconut oil you can
spread it on things you can cook with it
you can rub it on your body and
moisturize you can put it in your hair
if you have hair you could whiten your
teeth we were so happy the three of us
together then one morning I don't know
what happened she must have read an
article we were done with coconut oil I
don't know why but her reasons are my
reasons she's angry so I'm angry we're
done with it forever we're on to me so I
don't know how long it's gonna last I
can't question but I don't want to get
too attached to me so
smoothies are another big part of our
lives I didn't see that coming
smoothies because when you're single as
smoothie is just like a fun word that
you remember from time to time oh yeah
maybe I'll have one of those eventually
but when you're part of a couple is
smoothie is so much more it's like a
relationship lubricant you always have
something to talk about the next
smoothie what are we gonna have what do
we have do we have baby spinach do we
have berries are they in season do we
have avocado is it in that five minute
window and it's still good do we have
the milk of some sort of najin the nuts
are all battling it out to see you could
be milky as we always have fruits and
vegetables in the house now I didn't
realize it but when you're in a couple
you eat the fruits and vegetables that
you buy that was a revelation for me
because when you're single if you buy a
fruit or a vegetable it's like a wish
that will very likely not come true
we always do like that you know
different food-related things like geo
is a you want to do a food challenge I'm
like what like who could eat more wings
she's like no no we're eliminating
gluten dairy oils and fun I'm like no
you win that challenge I'm out we did a
cleanse of 30-day cleanse I was starving
for 30 days I was so hungry he was such
an unfamiliar feeling to be that hungry
because you see those commercials where
they're like millions of Americans go to
bed hungry every single night I was like
yeah I know I'm one of them and in a way
it's even more impressive because I have
access to food I can't end world hunger
but I can end my hunger I would get
these cryptic text from her when I'm on
the road all of a sudden my phone is
like bananas aren't clean I'm like I'll
tell the other is like what is this a
drug deal like I just want to eat my
breakfast bananas or a clean
oh really baby they were clean we
watched a lot of documentaries I've
never met anybody who's seen more
documentaries than my fiancee I
literally think that the eight years we
were apart she just watched
documentaries the entire time cuz
anytime one comes up I'm like oh let's
watch that she's like I read his heart
I'm like it just came out she's like I
was there when they shot it we watched
this documentary called banana land if
you like bananas I do not recommend
watching banana land like every
documentary it will [ __ ] room what
you love forever I won't tell you the
whole thing but uh if I could distill it
down to a single line towards the end of
banana land this woman this Central
American banana farmer looks right into
the camera and says just remember the
next time you eat a banana you're eating
pure violence great you know I should
knew we shouldn't watch this violence
weeds happen to like our smoothies with
pure violence
when my fiance first moved in we were
fighting a lot and it was difficult
because she's good at it and I'm getting
better and by that I mean I'm learning
to say I'm sorry I make it a habit I say
it regularly I say babe I love you
please forgive me I'm sorry and then she
says we can't just say I'm sorry it's
not just about saying the words I'm
sorry you have to understand what you
did you can't just say I'm sorry and
it's over and I say you're right I'm
sorry please forgive me I apologize and
then she says well it's not like this is
the first time I've said this to you up
said it many times before you just keep
doing the same thing over and over again
what are you gonna get a treat your head
when I say what the [ __ ] I'm not Hitler
I'm just a human being maybe you can cut
me some slack
[Laughter]
[Music]
actually I say I'm sorry please forgive
me I apologize because I love her I love
her very much but I disappoint her a lot
I've never been this disappointing to
another human being it's a very
unfamiliar terrain but I'm realizing
that that's what love is disappointment
when you find someone who you disappoint
regularly hold on to that person because
you have found true love to be fair
sometimes after a fight she'll come up
to me kind of sheepishly and say babe
I'm sorry I think I'm getting my period
and I say no no we're getting our period
because it is a shared suffering
she suffers physically and I do not and
I get it I think you know women have it
harder in this world I think men walk
around with a degree of privilege every
single day that they'll never fully
comprehend or so I'm told
[Laughter]
now I believe that's true I think men
have it easier I think women put up with
so much [ __ ] for men their entire lives
from the time they're little girls
whether its family teachers classmates
coaches bosses colleagues random
[ __ ] on the street that by the time
they settle on you it's like they
finally got through to customer service
and you are going to get an earful
because they are not happy with the
product
oh yeah they have got some complaints
that they've been sitting on for a very
long time and you just picked up you're
gonna be tempted to say things like oh
no I'm sorry that's not my department
let me transfer you but guess what it's
all your department now you're the only
one in the department so just get used
to saying things like I'm sorry please
forgive me I apologize and you have a
shot of keeping your job 48 years old I
find myself waking up injured now it's a
new thing go to sleep perfectly fine
wake up with like a strained calf
I don't remember running in the night I
thought I was just laying flat for eight
hours apparently I have to stretch
before I sleep I feel like I'm always
masking at least two injuries and then
as soon as one heals two more appear
it's just like they're never fully
healed and I know I look alright but I'm
like a lemon
you know when they describe a car as a
lemon looks nice but then under the hood
they're like ah looks like it was in a
flood down south
I was in Hawaii I had a gig in Maui
beautiful amazing I don't know if you've
ever been it's just the most majestic
place I was standing on the shore
looking at it the most blue beautiful
ocean an equally majestic blue sky just
contemplating life a wave washed ashore
hit my knee it buckled and it's still
not the same I don't think it'll ever be
the same
that's where I met water is a threat I
went to see a doctor he's like were you
playing basketball I was like no I was
standing still I was relaxing I've been
peeing sitting down decided to start
that phase of my life I wish I knew
about it sooner I didn't realize it was
an option the old guys make you figure
it out for yourself it's like the Zen
thing you have to just learn it ah it's
just gorgeous and I don't use that word
but it's just such a game-changing
gorgeous thing I just you know just sit
there you know I'm not even talking
about like be productive take your phone
out get things done I'm just talking
about sitting down just seeing what
happens let the young guys stand right
got hopes and dreams making plans got a
stream you can depend on
not me got a spotty flow I'm like an old
rapper just a lot of Oh what what make
some noise
a big basketball fan and I realized that
it's kind of common knowledge that the
first black baseball player was Jackie
Robinson 1947 Brooklyn Dodgers but I
realized I don't know who the first
black NBA player was I think it was just
the entire NBA like one day it was all
white the very next day it was all black
there was you don't have to show up
anymore we just realized you suck a
basketball we've made a horrible mistake
you could be a ref you could coach the
team you get on the team you could
literally do any other job you just
can't play anymore and some of those
white guys are are still in the Hall of
Fame who didn't play against black guys
the whole you know what the whole of
Fame how dare you you could work in the
Hall of Fame you could give tours you
could sweep up you just not have to be
in the Hall of Fame racism was really
like the first steroids like a
performance-enhancing drug like your
performance is definitely enhanced if
you're just playing basketball against
other white guys there's a league now of
all white guys there still is illegit
skald Division three college basketball
and it's awful it's unwatchable but if
this was 1940 they would be in the Hall
of Fame
I was thinking about how we're all
replaceable you know I think we're all
replaceable and I take great solace in
that
some people resist that you know because
they they attributed like to work or
achievement you know they're like no no
I my job I'm the only one you're not the
only one but I'm working on this project
nobody gives a [ __ ] about your project
it's stupid don't show up to work for a
few days and someone else will take over
your stupid project we're all
replaceable and I take comfort in that
Steve Jobs Apple Genius right the year
that he died I read that the very next
year Apple had its best year ever
there you go if Steve Jobs is
replaceable we're all replaceable Steve
Kerr coach of the Golden State Warriors
a few years ago he led them to the
championship the very next year he had
back surgery he was out his assistant
took over they went 24 and OH and went
on to the best record in NBA history the
next year he hurt his back again a
different assistant stepped in they went
all the way to the finals undefeated and
finally lost when he came back Steve
Kerr great coach very replaceable and
viv on The Fresh Prince he thought she
was irreplaceable guess what aunt Viv's
season three you're out
we're all just aunt Vivian our way
through life so guys as of the beginning
of my set Donald Trump is still our 45th
and final president
not looking good everyone it's like
mainlining anxiety with this guy right
you have to think about him every single
day from the moment you wake up you know
he's coming for you
right every day I don't even think about
my family every day I got to think about
this guy just gotta let you think about
what do you got what do you got Russia
what do you go North Korea what is it
and just tweet it oh it's so exhausting
right it's starting to feel like we're
the senior class of Earth right like if
there is an afterlife and there isn't
we're gonna walk in like
[Music]
we ended it
what did you guys do hey Thomas Edison
light bulb no more light Rosa Parks stay
seated
[Music]
it's a post-traumatic stress without the
post present traumatic stress it's so
exhausting especially in this age of
yoga and meditation mindfulness being
present in the net home Trump is like
the opposite of all that if you take
yoga Trump is what you've been preparing
for the whole time these teachers like
everyone this is not a test this is it
this is the real thing just breathe root
yourself in your practice and be present
in the now while we still have a now
this is called downward spiraling
Society Donald Trump's campaign slogan
was make America great again but it
might as well have been [ __ ] yoga
[Laughter]
you remember the night of the election
as the return started coming in you
start to have like that conspiracy brain
going right you know Trump was ahead
early and I was like I see what they're
doing they're gonna let him get ahead
early keep us watching and then at the
end of the night Hillary will be
president then later in the night
they're like Trump still ahead it's
still too close to call
we'll tell you in the morning I was like
I see what they're doing they're gonna
let's go to sleep think he's gonna be
President in the morning Hillary will be
president in the morning they like
Trump's president I was like I see what
they're doing they're gonna swear him in
let him govern for four years and then
Hillary will be president part of me
felt bad for Hillary just in the sense
that she's always liked the shore thing
can't lose always loses it's almost like
they're playing this game of what would
it take to get you to vote for Hillary
Clinton hear me out
what if she ran against a black guy with
the middle name Hussein no wow this is
gonna be a lot harder than I thought
okay okay all right how about this an
orange reality television star no
experienced racist and sexist still no
holy [ __ ] you really don't seem to like
her
everyone threatened to move to Canada on
both sides right didn't matter who you
were going to I'm moving to Canada it's
like we get it if your candidate loses
you're moving to the whitest
english-speaking country you can drive
to what about Mexico
I'm not that progressive I remember when
Barack Obama got elected a lot of people
said I wish my grandparents had lived to
see this the first black president in
American history and I know how they
feel now I wish my grandparents had
lived to see Trump get elected because
they were racist and this would have
been very very special for them on
account of how racist they were they
weren't just racist they had other
interests like my grandmother was an
excellent Baker but she was a racist
Baker and you could always taste it
there was always something off in every
recipe like how what is that spice ah
racism of course I should have guessed
now I'm not saying that everyone who
voted for Trump is racist I'm saying my
grandparents were and if you voted for
Trump you probably would have liked them
[Laughter]
to be fair to my grandparents they
weren't racist at the time they were
just white but a lot of times white is
just like races that hasn't been
diagnosed yet it's like you get the test
results back years later like oh we got
your results you were very racist the
whole entire time you should have been
tested more regularly you're in a very
high-risk group I voted for Bernie
Sanders in the Democratic primary most
people I just think that Bernie is the
face of America right now Bernie Sanders
is 74 years old and he's still looking
for a job what could be more American
than that but it was like a reality show
right the whole election cycle it was
kind of hard to look away it was it's
like governing with the Stars and like a
reality show
I like the early episodes though right
Bernie and Hillary they almost felt like
your grandparents but from opposite
sides of the family Bernie was like the
fun grandpa make sure that everybody
sharing and Hillary's like [ __ ] grandma
Hillary's coming this weekend this is
gonna suck smile for Grandma Hillary
[Laughter]
Trump's like you're mentally ill uncle
who just shows up on announce you never
know what he's gonna say or do like no
no I just let him talk this is gonna be
interesting
just keep them away from the grill and
the gardeners
so I don't know I don't know he's voting
the answer I doubt it
people get mad if you don't vote they'll
yell at you how dare how dare you how
how dare you people died so you could
vote yeah and people are gonna die
because you vote
enjoy your sticker right it's just it's
so disheartening that's never discussed
it's never discussed continuous murder
we're always just electing the next
murderer and chief sometimes we feel
good about it right sometimes we feel
progressive we had a black murderer and
chief also felt so progressive and we
almost had a woman murdering around the
globe
right breaking the glass ceiling and
then the shards of glass falling
murdering people
then the ex-presidents once they're out
of office right they do a 180 they they
rebrand Obama's going windsurfing with
billionaires george w bush's a painter
all of a sudden ah right having food
through that george w bush right he's
like mr. Magoo with a paintbrush all of
a sudden taking selfies with Michelle
Obama and Allen he's so likeable and fun
he did a reverse Hitler Hitler was a
painter and then he murdered a [ __ ]
skateboard
they said never forget George we didn't
forget it all goes by so quickly though
right sometimes you forget it all just
goes by so quickly that you forget do
you remember when Jeb Bush was the
presumptive nominee you remember that
it's supposed to be Jeb Bush against
Hillary Clinton right just like God
ordained the two royal families battling
it out Jeb Bush just disappeared but he
resurfaced recently did you hear what
have people at the Miami Marlins
baseball team that was his plan B maybe
I'll be president maybe I'll buy a
baseball team nothing takes the edge off
losing like owning some human beings huh
historically speaking that really takes
the edge off and he wasn't even the
first person in his family to do that
George W Bush owned the Texas Rangers I
think in the 90s the fourth-place Texas
Rangers couldn't even figure out the
American League we put him in charge of
America Donald Trump in the 80s he owned
the New Jersey generals of the
now-defunct USFL doesn't exist anymore
for whatever that's worth and recently
Trump got into trouble for claiming to
know more about Isis than the generals
and it finally occurred to me like oh he
probably meant the New Jersey generals
that makes a little more sense still
probably wrong but at least it does make
some sense Don I call him Don Trump
every now and then it takes the edge off
just hits the ear different right Donald
Trump Don Trump almost sounds like a
personal injury lawyer Lee Don from have
you been injured or an accident dial do
n TR um leave the less Pete Martin
Luther King jr. if he was just Marty
King I don't know would you be on board
with his dream
Marty King probably just wants to play
Vegas
Marty King limited time only at Caesar's
Palace Mother Teresa she was just mama
Terry hey mama Terry when you're here
you're famished it up but up but up but
our Papa why his mother Teresa have an
Italian restaurant he was a bad business
woman wonderful woman horrible business
Jesus was a bad businessman too right
just gave everything away for free
that's why there's no Jesus School of
Economics people who say Jesus is my
personal Lord and Savior do you ascribe
to his economic policy
[Music]
I was raised Catholic and now I'm not
that's usually the end of that sentence
rarely you hear I was raised Catholic
and now I'm [ __ ] really Catholic
[Laughter]
I think it's a good starter kit
Catholicism it's good for kids you have
good characters Jesus and Santa Claus
right when you're a kid those are the
two characters both great guys giving
things away for free both Socialists
basically that's what you're
indoctrinated with Santa going around
the world just giving people toys Jesus
turning one thing into another thing
giving it away for free
water into wine at the wedding when they
ran out it's not like oh and then Jesus
made a [ __ ] killing because it's a
wedding and they need wine right place
right time market supply and demand
[ __ ] Jesus if Jesus came back now the
bar would be so much lower he wouldn't
have to turn water into wine he could
just turn water into clean drinking
water show up in Flint Michigan that
people will be like Jesus it's a miracle
we can drink this yeah please go ahead
drink it I just put a British label on
this it's not even America really what's
it about though right what's it about
you can't just walk around feeling
dispirited I think it's about the
movements the movements that have been
coalescing even before Trump got into
office Occupy Wall Street black lives
matter some people say well what about
all life's don't all lives matter yeah
they do but this is called black lives
matter they already decided on a name
and if your first contribution to the
movement is suggesting a name change
maybe you're not as in it as you think
you are show up to a couple more
meetings and stand in the back quietly
the movements right fight for 15 the
Muslim ban people showed up flooded the
airports all over the country people
showed up for these people who are being
banned a lot of people are refugees
leaving violent
oppression fleeing running for their
lives have you ever moved that sucks
you have to waste a whole weekend you
gotta get boxes banned bother your
friends my last move was from the second
floor to the fourth floor of the same
building and it was an ordeal I hope I
never have to go through ever again I'm
still scarred there wasn't a war on the
second floor I just had a better view on
the fourth the movement's dakota
pipeline the pepsi movement if you
didn't hear about the pepsi movement let
me fill you in
pepsi did this commercial that caused a
bit of a stir because they kind of
co-opted all of these movements that
have been going on and they spit it out
as commercialism in this commercial
kendall Jenner who was a person I just
found out about she's of the house and
lineage of Jenner she's on a photo shoot
a very glamorous photoshoot there's a
wind machine I think and as she's on
this photo shoot a protest march goes by
and people are holding signs with such
nuanced messages as peace and love
you know those peace and love marches
we've been seeing so much of catch's
Kendall Jenner's eye but that's not what
gets her in a little later on there's
this cute boy who kind of flirts with
her and beckons her into the movement
and that's when kendall Jenner realizes
hey I think I'm down with the peace and
love movement she rips off her blonde
wig of course wipes off her lipstick you
know against protest ready
and not only does she join the movement
she goes right to the frontlines and
what does she do she gives a police
officer an ice-cold Pepsi everyone
cheers and world peace is declared
thanks to Kendall Jenner and Pepsi oh
how could you possibly be offended by
that on the bright side at least we
finally found our first paid protestor
[Laughter]
but I don't blame kendall Jenner come on
she's a 13 year old girl who doesn't
know whether her father's her mother or
mother's her father she's got a lot to
sort through I blame the comedians and
actors who do commercials for the big
banks just years after the bank's
crashed the economy and then they're
doing fun commercials like hey what's in
your wallet
not much [ __ ] what's in yours but
it's just you know that's the culture
now everyone's for sale right how did we
get here we get here journalists like to
ask that right coming up next how did we
get a president Trump I don't know have
you ever been watching a television show
or a movie where a journalist appears as
themselves Wolf Blitzer suddenly on
house of cards playing Wolf Blitzer
I don't know wolf how do we get here
Rachel Maddow playing Rachel Maddow all
of them Brian Williams Anderson Cooper
how did we get here I don't know maybe
because when you're interviewing Frank
Underwood one minute and Donald Trump
the next we don't believe you anymore
you're not a journalist you're an actor
maybe that's the problem wolf maybe
that's how we got here
maybe because your role on house of
cards
means more to you than your role as the
Fourth Estate in our democracy maybe
that's how we got here by the way I'm
not criticizing their acting Wolf
Blitzer gave a very fine performance as
Wolf Blitzer very very convincing it was
nuanced I believed entirely that he was
a fake journalist with no integrity
wonderful air wonderful hair but they're
all cut from the same cloth right that's
the culture now Fame [ __ ] just looking
for money looking for a higher profile
there's no difference between kendall
Jenner and Donald Trump in the 90s
Donald Trump did Pizza Hut commercials
Pizza Hut do you know who owned Pizza
Hut Pepsi we are about 20 years in a sex
change operation away from president Ken
Jenner and I plan on voting for him
because he's got a long track record
with the peace and love movement
so it's the movements everybody it's the
movements we the senior-class of Earth
are tasked with doing what we can you
have to join the movement see what's
going on plug in right all the Marches
of women's March the climate March the
science March the scientists are
marching that's how bad it's gotten they
don't even like going outdoors they have
[ __ ] to research they should be inside
you have to give up a Saturday because
the president doesn't believe in climate
science thinks it's a hoax you know the
way those scientists are always trying
to pull a fast one on us ha ha ha you
rapscallions fool me once and then prove
it over and over and over again have it
reviewed by your peers until it's a fact
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Trump is talking about immigrants and
Muslims I'm from New York City
immigrants and Muslims oh you mean the
people who make our lives convenient and
delicious first of all we're all
immigrants I'm not from Earth are you I
have no idea how I got here I don't know
how long I'm allowed to stay but I don't
think I've ever had a meal in New York
City that was in either prepared or
delivered by an immigrant almost every
cab in New York driven by a Muslim for
New Yorkers a Muslim extremist is just
someone who gets you there faster
whoa I think that light was red that's a
little extreme
I remember the week of Trump's
inauguration do you remember that the
week of Trump's inauguration it began if
you remember on the Monday with MLK Day
and then it ended on Friday with Trump's
inauguration struck me as odd bookends
MLK a man who told us to judge people
not by the color of their skin but by
the content of their character and I
don't know what's more disturbing the
color of Trump skin or the content of
his character thank you so much
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you